WILL COME TO ORDER GOOD MORNING
IN RESPONSE TO- THE ECHO
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND PROTECT
THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
EMPLOYEES MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND
HERE'S SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
JUDGMENTS NORMAL PRACTICES IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARING
HERE IN THE CAPITAL- WITH. AT
THE MOMENT THREE MEMBERS
PRESIDENT. R. ONE ON TO COME
SHORTLY CENTER TAUGHT OR BUY
SHARES NOT ABLE TO ATTEND TODAY
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHOSE
DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED. I'D
LIKE TO ANNOUNCE THAT AB FIVE
THREE FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUILAR CURRY HAS BEEN PUT OVER
AND WILL NOT BE HEARD TODAY.
FOR THOSE THAT MAY BE IN
ATTENDANCE ON FOR THAT
PARTICULAR MATTER. THAT LEAVES
FOR BILLS REMAINING ON THE
AGENDA ALL FOUR BILLS ARE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR THEIR FILE
ITEMS ONE TWO FOUR AND FIVE
THAT'S A BABY'S THREE NINE ONE.
FOUR TWO FIVE ELEVEN OH THREE
IN THIRTEEN SIXTY TWO. AS WE
ARE TAKING UP. ONLY THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WILL NOT TAKE
TESTIMONY TODAY HOWEVER YOUR
COMMENTS ARE IMPORTANT IF YOU
HAVE TESTIMONY LIKE- THE
COMMITTEE TO HAVE PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR TESTIMONY IN WRITING- IN
YOU CAN DO SO BY VISITING THE
SENATE AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE FOR CONTACT INFORMATION.
WE WILL TAKE A MOMENTARY PAUSE
AS WE AWAIT- OUR COLLEAGUES SO
THAT WE CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
THERE WE GO. LET'S GO AHEAD
AND- ESTABLISH A QUOTA QUORUM
CONSULTING PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PORGES PRESENT OR JUST PRESENT
HER TADO. CABALLERO PRESENT
CAREER PRESENT EGGMAN GLAZERS
GLAZER PRESENT IN MARIN THE
CONSULTANT NOTES A QUORUM HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED WILL NOW TAKE
UP OUR ONE ITEM OF BUSINESS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR DO I HAVE A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
OUR AYE CONSENT CALENDAR HAS
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR GLAZER A
CONSULTANT CAME PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ON THE A CONSENT CALENDAR
CONSISTING OF ITEMS ONE TWO
FOUR AND FIVE AB. 391-425-1103
AND THIRTEEN SIXTY TWO.
GORGEOUS FIVE PORTICI.
CABALLERO CAREER HI GLAZER AYE
GLAZER AYE. THANK YOU. OKAY WE
WILL PUT THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ON CALL- A RESPECT FOR A
COLLEAGUE- WHO IS IN A
LEADERSHIP CONFERENCE- IF WE
COULD NOTIFY- HEARD THAT- WE
ARE AWAITING HER ARRIVAL. THE.
BY LOOKS LIKE OUR TIME TABLE IS
GOING TO REQUIRE A LITTLE BIT
MORE- SO WITH THAT WHEN WE GO
IN RECESS. FOR ANOTHER FIFTEEN
MINUTES. AND HOPEFULLY THAT'S
ENOUGH TIME FOR ALL- COME ON
OVER THANK YOU.
BACK TO ORDERS
OF THE BIT OF A OF THE CALENDAR
CENTER EGGMAN IS NOW PRESENT-
IF YOU COULD LIVE THE CALL.
YEAH THE TABLE WITH A ROLL
AGAIN. OKAY. SO THE ROLL CALL
FOR SENATE AG COMMITTEE-
CABALLERO. EGGMAN HERE EGGMAN
PRESENT SORRY. RIGHT AND ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR CONSISTING OF
ITEMS ONE TWO FOUR AND FIVE AB.
391-425-1103 TEN THIRTEEN SIXTY
TWO. HER TADO. EGGMAN HI EGGMAN
I GOT FOR VOTERS OKAY- I
BELIEVE THAT COMPLETES TODAY'S
AGENDA DOES ROOT RATHER QUICKLY
THANK YOU CENTER EGGMAN I KNOW
YOU WERE IN LEADERSHIP MEETINGS
ALL RIGHT IF YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING IT TO THE AG COMMITTEE
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US THEY WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS THANK
YOU APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE INCLUDED
THE AGENDA SENATE AG COMMITTEE
ON AGRICULTURE IS ADJOURNED.